[Music]
the committee will come to order
you are here
because the American people need the
truth about the threat Tick-Tock poses
to our national and personal security
the debate over whether Tick Tock should
be banned in the United States largely
ignores broader issues around data
accessibility privacy and Chinese
Espionage the marketplace for buying and
selling data collected by internet
companies is unregulated and can be
predatory yet it's often legal a ban on
Tick Tock would at best act as a
Band-Aid rather than a solution to this
problem to get to the heart of the issue
Americans need a deeper understanding of
how their data is being manipulated by
companies in ways that allow foreign and
Anonymous entities like the Chinese
Communist party to obtain private
information at a cost without protective
legislation in place everyday Americans
including journalists are at risk of
being targeted and spied on
I don't think I thought they were spying
on me until I learned that they were
spying on me Federal prosecutors in the
FBI are investigating tick tock's parent
company for possible surveillance of
journalists who cover the technology
industry when I found out I was
I I felt sort of like a disappointed
parent I was really unimpressed the
company admitted it by dance tells NBC
it's investigating the spying internally
and will cooperate with any official
inquiries because this is a company that
has tried so hard in so many different
ways to convince lawmakers around the
world that they are not misusing data
that there is no surveillance that there
is no spying there is no threat for a
company that has been really trying to
establish trust in that area this was
such an unforced error they didn't get
anything particularly valuable out of
looking at my location data what I'm
much more worried about is that if some
people in China could pull my data for a
somewhat nefarious purpose they could
also pull the data of Chinese dissidents
living in the United States or military
operatives or people who actually could
be seriously put at risk if their
location data fell into the wrong hands
scrutiny over the popular app Tick Tock
is going we have said we have concerns
with this particular app Tick Tock it's
really a question of data collection
your platform should be banned has bike
dance spied on American citizens I don't
think that spying is the right way to
describe It ultimately
is ultimately an internal
so they're really sort of two buckets of
National Security concerns about Tick
Tock the first bucket is what some
people call sort of data Espionage or
fear of data exfiltration that fear is
that the Chinese government could use
tick tock through its Chinese parent
company bite dance to collect
information about American citizens and
then use that in ways that are adverse
to U.S national security the second
bucket of concerns is that the Chinese
government could through tick tock's
Chinese parent company by dance seek to
very subtly influence the
recommendations algorithm that
determines what people see and thus
influence our Civic discourse our
conversations about things like Finance
Health Etc that could have a really real
effect on American society
Tick Tock is potentially effective as an
Espionage tool because China has a full
Suite of tools they spy from space
that's why the bullying thing was a
little silly if you have a satellite you
don't need a balloon the Chinese have
human agents they probably have several
dozen spies operating in the U.S at any
given moment and of course the coerce uh
individuals into cooperation if you know
you have family in China they show up
and say play ball with us or uh grandma
gets it but the best source of Espionage
for the Chinese is hacking it's cyber
Espionage and Tick Tock provides an
Avenue for increased cyber Espionage
cyber Espionage is how the Chinese have
done the most damage to this country
white dance narrative is that they're
not doing anything bad and
there's two problems with that first
occasionally they've been caught doing
something bad like when they were
tracking journalists but it doesn't
matter they could be they could be
Saints because Chinese law says it is
the Chinese government asks a company to
cooperate it has no choice no appeal no
going to court no laying across the
railroad tracks and so by dance they
could be perfectly innocent today and if
Xi Jinping wakes up in a bad mood
tomorrow they could be doing something
bad that's the main problem is that the
Chinese are the world's largest
Espionage country when it comes to
targeting the US
the watch time with Tick Tock is rapidly
evolving and the stats are constantly
changing because it's still growing in
popularity but the latest data that we
have shows that about 100 million
Americans are on Tick Tock and on
average they're watching Tick Tock for
90 minutes a day competing with Prime
Time viewership what's different about
zigzag algorithm is the speed at which
it can pick in a specific interest of
the user and the main driver of physics
is the amount of Behavioral data that is
being collected due to the design of the
platform which is very short videos on
which the user has to scroll or watch or
like and so for every single piece of
content that the algorithm recommends
there is an action on the user side
which then is used to feed the algorithm
with more training data about its
specific interests on YouTube if I watch
an hour of YouTube tube and watch maybe
10 to 15 different videos which will get
10 to 15 data points to YouTube to know
okay was I interested in this particular
topic or not based on the fact that I
like the video watched it in entirely or
subscribed to the to the channel on Tick
Tock it's every 10 seconds or even less
that I will give a data point to tick
tock about whether I am interested in
this topic or not
surveillance advertising is a business
model that's used by most major social
media platforms today and what that
entails is the collection of data on
users there's nefarious types of data
and there's more innocuous types of data
they're collecting all of it so they're
looking at what are you doing while
you're on the app that makes sense right
so on Facebook what posts are you liking
what things are you sharing what are you
engaging with but they're also doing
things that you may not know that
they're doing they're tracking your
location they're looking at who you
spend time around where physically you
are they're collecting all of that data
and then they're using it to sell to
advertisers but it can also be more
nefarious you can Target people in
discriminatory ways based on race or
gender or you can selectively not Target
them for things like housing
opportunities for jobs broader than that
on these platforms they collect this
data and then when they don't have any
profitability left from selling advert
to advertisers on their platform form
they sell it to data Brokers which are
third-party people totally unassociated
from the platforms people that you don't
know you've never consented to them
receiving any information about you you
know that you know of you checked a box
and a long long paragraph of terms when
you join the platform and never thought
about it again but they take that data
and they package it and they sell it to
literally anybody anybody can buy this
information and it's been used in really
dangerous ways sometimes people will buy
packages of information labeled help I'm
a senior and I'm 90 days behind on bills
and they will buy that information and
Target those people with advertisements
for predatory refinance programs to to
get in and get ownership of their homes
and take advantage of them in other
cases there have been instances where
women are being stalked and their
stalker goes in and buys a package of
data based on their gender and location
and is able to discern with specificity
who they are in that data package stock
them find them and attack them there's
nothing preventing the Chinese
government the CCP or anybody else for
that matter from going in and buying
that data from them and from those data
Brokers you have publicly said that you
do not support Banning the app why well
listen I think Tick Tock first of all
has got 150 million users across the
country it speaks the Next Generation
something that's really surprised me
about the way that we're talking about
this issue now too is who's jumping into
the fight and what their motivation is
should we tell our children and
everybody that we know to take Tick-Tock
off of their devices
I would maybe America has finally
reached the point where we realize that
our innermost
Secrets privacy security or at stake
here funding lobbyists to go to Capitol
Hill and talk about how dangerous Tick
Tock is we've got huge broadcast
networks doing the same thing but their
lobbyists aren't going and talking about
the problem with the surveillance
advertising model which is really the
problem they're going to say ban it why
do they want it banned because they want
that 90 minutes of attention span back
from 100 million Americans a day that's
money that they're missing I encourage
our lawmakers to think really critically
about who are these lobbyists stocking
on their doors and what are their
motivations
foreign
company bite dance is also the company
that first built Tick Tock the app at
first Tick Tock was just another of bite
dances apps by dance has been called an
app Factory in China it's made many apps
over the course of numerous years both
domestically in China and
internationally and Tick Tock was just
another of those apps it then blew up
became really prominent and it became
important for tick tock to start to say
that they have some independence from
bike dance and so Tick Tock Incorporated
is its own entity it's now its own
company but internally there isn't very
much distinction between Tick Tock and
bite dance Tick Tock employees have told
me some of them signed contracts with
Tick Tock but got paid by by dance or
got a W-2 from bite dance we found that
there are a lot of people who now work
at bike dance and Tick Tock who
previously worked for Chinese State
media outlets and in one sense this
isn't super surprising because fight
dances at china-based Chinese company
and
all media in China basically is State
media and so you're going to have a lot
of overlap there but that overlap seems
really significant to me for a couple
reasons first of all it means that all
those people in their foreign jobs were
used to abiding by the party line about
what types of content was allowed what
wasn't and what types of messages should
be promoted that was just part of the
job so the fear is that that expectation
could continue into their work at bite
dance the other reason it's significant
is because Tick Tock and bite dance have
tried over and over again to say that
they have nothing to do with the Chinese
government and nothing to do with the
Chinese Communist party but bite dance
which operates apps in China has to work
with the Chinese Communist party and the
Chinese government all the time on their
domestic apps and so they have to
maintain relations with the Chinese
government in order to run their
businesses in China
I work in politics and Tech policy and
here's what they don't want you to know
about the push to ban Tick Tock as a
tick tock Creator myself I've had
interesting experiences on the app I've
definitely noticed certain degrees of
censorship on different topics at
different times I've noticed my reach be
restricted particularly when I'm talking
about political topics related to
electoral politics or during election
season I don't know enough about the
algorithm to try and make a an assertion
as to why or what exactly is going on
there
I have over 60 000 followers and when my
average viewership is in the thousands
and I have a video that in multiple days
only has a couple hundred views you know
something is is off and it's certainly
something that I've noticed it's really
a platform designed for virality in the
sense that a single piece of content can
reach a lot of users so for example on
YouTube or Instagram the number of views
that a content creator would get is much
more consistent on Tick Tock it's very
likely or common that a content creator
will get thousands of you on their
videos typically and suddenly they get a
video at one million view but it can
happen to anyone that suddenly you get a
super viral piece of content which sort
of also fuels a dream that anyone can
get really popular on tick tock
thank you
[Music]
as a war in Ukraine unfolded we became
very curious to know what content would
be recommended both in Ukraine and in
Russia the Ukrainian side had obviously
for a lot of really critical content
about the war and most of the uh
Ukrainian Tick Tock was a anti-war and
anti-kremlin and Russia was a very
interesting important market for for
tick tock in fact the fifth biggest
market for tick tock in the world which
is which is quite big but also Tick Tock
had a quite crucial role to play in the
beginning of the conflict in particular
because there was a lot of dissent from
people and content that was highly
critical of the Kremlin that was
circulating on Tick Tock and so there
was even a sense that Tick Tock could be
a fuel for a revolution or like at least
a social movement against a Kremlin in
Russia in the same ways and Facebook had
been during the Arabs rings and what we
saw was in fact like quite the opposite
very soon after the the war unfolded the
Kremlin put up what they call the fake
news law which forbid the use of a lot
of words including world war in Russian
media the way that a lot of social media
platform responded was by completely
shutting down the service the Facebook
and Instagram for example were
discontinued tick tock on the other end
responded in a way that was quite
surprising all International content was
made unavailable to Russian users upload
of new content was blocked so basically
Russian users were left with an old
Russian Tick Tock instead of having a
live International tick tock
who's challenging Marine Le Pen to
France's far right opposition
what we didn't drink as a French
election was to monitor the prominence
of the different candidates in the
algorithmic recommendation made on Tick
Tock and YouTube and so we compared how
much each of the different candidate was
being promoted by the algorithm and what
we found was that the most right-leaning
and polarizing candidate whose name was
Eric zemu was largely by far the most
promoted on the on the platform
foreign
recommended on YouTube ended up being
much more representative of the
different candidates and much more
balanced while on Tick Tock since it was
just normal content creator trying to
get the buzz they would most of them
would try to go for the most polarizing
candidates and topics
[Music]
in October I learned through my sourcing
at Tick Tock and by dance that a team at
bite dance that was investigating leaks
to me
was planning to use my location data
pulled from The Tick Tock app in order
to try to figure out who was talking to
me and they were going to do that by
trying to match my IP address to the IP
addresses of their own employees and say
if I was at a coffee shop at the same
time as one of their employees that
might have meant that they were talking
to me the project name was called
project Raven we wrote about that at the
time in October but we wrote about it in
a pretty vague way because we had to
protect the people who were telling us
what was going on inside the company and
so we couldn't say who was being
surveilled and we couldn't say why they
were being surveilled but from our
sourcing we knew that the company was
interested in the movements and
whereabouts of me Catherine Schwab and
rich nieva in response to our reporting
bike dance started an investigation of
their own saying why do these reporters
think this is true and they learned that
that team had in fact accessed location
data and try to figure out who was
sourcing me it turns out they also had
accessed location data on another
reporter who works with the financial
times in London so they fired people who
had accessed the data and they also
stripped data access to that particular
team so they they took actions to try to
ensure that this particular variant of
data misuse couldn't happen again what I
don't know is whether another similarly
situated team that still has that data
access could lead to data misuse in the
future
our story is based off of the work of a
researcher based in Vienna named Felix
Krauss and what he found was that Tick
Tock has the ability to track the Taps
and keystrokes of users when they visit
outside websites through tick tock's
in-app browser that could be potentially
you know very personal information so
things like passwords if you're logging
into something credit card information
if you're trying to buy something what
he found was that Tick Tock has the
ability to do this not necessarily that
they are doing it but they do have the
ability to do it and it's an ability
that none of the other apps that he
tested has when we reached out to talk
for comment they did confirm that these
features exist in the code but they said
they weren't using them they said that
they exist for debugging and performance
tracking purposes
if you're going to post a tick tock
that's critical of tick tock itself you
have to be mindful of the fact that that
content very well may be oppressed
creators like myself have come to learn
how to use certain code words you can
say the clock app you can say this very
app that we're on right now when I did
some content creation myself around the
Forbes journalists being targeted by
Tick Tock I definitely noticed that when
I posted it originally without mincing
words the reach was suppressed when I
posted it again refilmed it and took a
different approach using Code words not
speaking is directly this very app the
we are on right now it was not
suppressed in the same way China has a
couple strategies when it comes to tick
tock and the core of it is they love
Tick Tock they love Tick Tock for two
reasons it's their only globally
successful app so it's the only one
downloaded all over the world the second
reason they love it is it's a great way
to get on your phone I'm not saying
they're spying but if they wanted to
they're on your phone you don't know
what they're putting in the Chinese
foreign Ministry is kind of like a
public relations firm and they don't
really actually connect that tightly to
the policy making decisions so of course
they're going to say that nobody ever
says oh you caught me I'm sorry I won't
spy again nobody says that but the
Chinese are going to say not only is it
not our fault but it's your fault
because why are you so mean to us so
China's strategy is typical deny say
it's someone else's fault but never
admit
[Music]
Indian government has banned dozens of
chinese-owned apps over apparent
security concerns now the list includes
the messaging service WeChat and the
wildly popular video platform Tick Tock
India Beyond Tech talk a few years ago
and it became very quickly this sort of
guide star for other countries that had
their own concerns about the app what we
discovered recently in our latest Forge
reporting was that even though the app
has been banned in India for close to
three years it was banned there in June
of 2020. any user data that had already
been collected on the Indian population
which was close to 200 million people
who were using the app in the country
all of that past user data is actually
still accessible by anybody who works
for tick tock or bite dance the reason
that that raised questions was because
nobody quite knows why the company had a
need to retain all this very sensitive
personal data on who people are where
they live who their social connections
are on the app there were a couple of
different ways that we were able to find
out that this past Indian user data was
widely accessible inside the company I
can't go into all of it here but what I
can say is that after speaking with a
current Tick Tock employee and also
reviewing some things of my own I was
able to see that there is this internal
tool that the employee had actually
jokingly described as quote NSA to go
the reason that person referred to it as
such is because this tool can actually
pull up a social graph or a social
Matrix of any Tick Tock user past or
present and it basically Maps out in
very granular detail who that person is
you've got the region where they live
you've got their closest connections is
basically a list from closest connection
to weakest connection at the bottom and
then other very detailed information
about them such as how these people
communicate with each other who they
follow Etc we published this story about
about Indian user data post tick tock
Ban two days before the CEO of tiktok
testified before Congress for the first
time ever the story was actually brought
up by a congresswoman who asked The Tick
Tock CEO shochu directly about the
report
a current Tick Tock employee told Forbes
that nearly anyone with basic access to
company tools including employees in
China can easily look up the closest
contacts and other sensitive information
about any user and The Tick Tock CEO
disputed the conclusions of the article
why would a current Tick-Tock employees
say this if it wasn't true this is a
recent article I have asked my team to
look into it as far as I know there is
we have rigorous data access protocols
this really no such thing but anybody
can get access to tools so I disagree
with a lot of the conclusions we know
because of the evidence that we have and
we're very confident about both our
reporting on our source saying that
there is in fact contrary to what the
tick tock CEO said under Ode to Congress
there is in fact widespread access to
this user data in the course of
reporting the story We reached out to
tick tock and by fans for comment they
kept asking for more time to respond and
when they finally did respond what they
emphasized was that they remain fully
compliant with the order from the Indian
government that had come down when the
government there actually banned the app
back in 2020.
foreign
I think one of the things that
government officials are trying to do
now is fully understand what Banning
Tick Tock would mean it would obviously
have some pretty significant effects for
the U.S economy a lot of businesses make
a lot of money on Tick Tock today a lot
of businesses reach a lot of their
consumers on Tick Tock but when you add
on to that the fact that China might
well retaliate and cut off business
avenues for U.S businesses doing
business in China or elsewhere abroad
and the sort of spiraling effects of
such a big decision in U.S China
relations I think are really hard to
fully anticipate there are sort of third
and fourth order potential effects of
this decision that that could really
throw the international economy out of
whack around the same time that the tick
tock CEO testified before Congress for
the first time I wrote a story for
Forbes on what a potential tip-tock ban
would do to the American economy and how
it would affect creators and small
businesses that have been using the app
now for years the story focused among
many other things on a few creators and
a few small businesses who had used the
app to really not only get their
businesses off the ground but to grow
sort of Empires out of these businesses
that they never even realized could
really be sustainable one example was
this this man named Casey Everton he had
started a garbage can cleaning business
in Utah Casey had been trying for a very
long time to get the business off the
ground by buying Facebook ads he said it
had been more than a whole year he was
trying to get traction no traction for
him so he took a cue from his teenage
daughter he got on Tick Tock he started
posting and just a few weeks in he went
viral similarly this woman named Jazz
Sears started a very small taco stand
outside of a local liquor store in her
town in Arizona she'd been cleaning
homes and her husband had worked at a
local Mail company and when covet hit
they were both out of their jobs they
couldn't keep working they opened this
local Taco Stand several weeks in a
random customer posted a tick tock and
the next day 300 cars showed up as the
US government and lawmakers are thinking
about banning Tick Tock there's the big
complicating factor that is all of the
Americans and businesses that actually
rely on it I think that the small
businesses and the medium-sized
businesses that will be affected by this
feel like all of the political chaos and
Crossfire has really overlooked not only
the opportunities that have been
afforded to them but also all the jobs
that have been created because of this
the most popular social media app by a
large margin is there a chance that it
vanishes people say ban a lot when it
comes to tick tock we should ban Tick
Tock because it's bad for America they
also say Devastator and the problem is
neither idea makes any sense KMBC news
has learned the White House is now
demanding its Chinese parent company by
dance sell at stake in the app or else
face a possible ban here in the U.S You
Can't Ban Tick Tock if you want to go
look at Vladimir Putin's website there's
nothing that gets in your way the first
amendment protects your right to look at
this kind of material and that includes
ridiculous as it might seem lip-syncing
teenagers Tick Tock is protected speech
when we started talking about this four
years ago Tick Tock was still pretty
small there were a couple big companies
that looked at maybe buying to Walmart
was one Microsoft was another these days
Walmart and Microsoft could not afford
to buy Tick Tock it's so valuable some
people say 40 or 50 billion dollars and
no American company has 40 or 50 billion
dollars lying around if a ban doesn't go
through it will probably be because Tick
Tock and the government reach an
agreement of some kind and that
agreement will require more transparency
from Tick Tock about how its algorithms
are recommending content and more data
protections for U.S citizens that's good
the question is sort of whether that can
be enough if bite dance still controls
Tick Tock but even if the government
decides that can be enough that's more
than what we have right now which is
just nothing getting out of this
situation is going to be difficult
because it's not a simple answer it's
going to require multiple different
solutions thoughtful solutions from
lawmakers who unfortunately based on you
know a lack of experience with these
platforms themselves really struggle to
both comprehend and also take action
quickly on these issues there is hope I
want to start there there is hope the
Federal Trade Commission has just
started a rulemaking process related to
data privacy and if that goes the way
that you know many of us are hoping it's
going to ago we will soon have rules out
of the Federal Trade Commission that
will limit the way that sensitive data
is used sold and abused by social media
companies and really any company online
that's not going to happen tomorrow it's
probably not going to happen next month
it's probably not going to happen next
year so is that enough no but it's a
start and I think that there's other
things that we can do that are going to
be better answers to this problem right
we need legislative answers
thank you
[Music]